ought to peace but they'll engage
instead in dialogue
and turkey's president has come out
firmly against russia saying it's
threatening peace across the region
i would like to start by saying that
russia's military action against
ukrainian territory which started this
morning is unacceptable and that we
reject it this step which we see as
being against international law is a
heavy blow to regional peace tranquility
and stability
we sincerely regret that russia and
ukraine both of whom we consider friends
and with whom we have close political
economic and social ties have come to
confront one another in this way
in istanbul with more on this tell us
more about turkey's position because the
president said it there he said these
guys are both our friends
well yes turkey has trying to position
itself in the middle since the beginning
of this conflict because turkey is the
is one of the crucial nato allies on the
eastern flank but despite that it has a
little bit complicated relations when it
comes to russia a strategic partnership
in syria again in libya in azerbaijan's
karabaw in the armenia azerbaijan
conflict
so this is a very important process for
turkey as president erdogan marked it
last week saying that
turkey would neither give up on ukraine
nor russia both countries are strong
trade partners for turkey and they have
dependent
relationships especially when it comes
to russia turkey is dependent on its
energy supplies also for the tourism so
so far turkey tried to take a diplomatic
mediation step but we haven't seen any
fruits of that of those uh
cherishes so far on the diplomatic table
uh but we haven't heard any turkish
authority using the word condemnation in
their written or oral statements so far
so uh it's it is so clear that turkey is
still trying to see the outcome of the
conflict and maybe it doesn't ha it
doesn't believe that it is going to turn
out to be a big war also trying to uh
spot uh spot itself in a safe place
otherwise
turkey's national interest and
geopolitical position might be at stake
especially when it comes to
the
re-evaluation of the mantra convention
of 1936
which gives turkey right to shut down
the waterways in the black sea yeah i
wanted to ask you quickly about that the
the waterways which are so crucial
because you know
it was
ukrainian ambassador takata was with me
earlier saying that's the type of thing
they're actually looking for not things
beyond sanctions actual concrete
measures
uh well yes i mean uh turkey according
to mantra convention turkey can shut
down the black sea waterways however if
it it closes that because the monto
convention actually binds the countries
that have coasts in the black sea
when you compare turkey and russia to
countries like romania bulgaria they
don't have the navies like turkey and
russia do so technically in the military
terms turkey and russia are sharing the
black sea if turkey shuts down the black
sea waterways
to russia while there are no warships or
other things then moscow may ask for uh
the re-evaluation of the mantra
convention and in turkey uh the the the
state actually uh the establishment
believes that the mantra convention is
the best deal that turkey could ever get
in the last 100 years so
this might be a disadvantage for turkey
and turkey wouldn't actually risk it
with the view from istanbul thank you
well let's take you through some
pictures which are